change lives change organizations
organizations change the world
thank you thank you very much indeed
general angle on that's very kind of you
it's wonderful to be here at this
extraordinary institution of of Stanford
it's probably the only place where I get
questions on a live Twitter feed which
if I knew what that was would be a help
but anyway this is a generational thing
I sure I would say to people about about
technology because the thing is when I
was UK Prime Minister I really didn't
have any access to technology at all in
fact I didn't even have a mobile phone
okay which in the light of recent events
in the UK is probably just as well but
so I I literally but but I got my first
piece of technology about which I was
inordinately excited the day after I
left office I got in my hand my first
piece of technology which was a mobile
phone right and I thought I'd
immediately send a a text an SMS so I
sent one to one of my old friends saying
hi how are you and because I'm
technologically ignorant I didn't
realize my name didn't automatically
come up on the text so I got a message
back saying sorry but who are you
and I remember sitting there thinking
it's been 24 hours
so anyway I am delighted to be here I'd
like to say big word of thanks to
Stanford to Garth to seed Bob and Dottie
King and everyone who supports what is a
amazing and innovative program and set
out for you I mean I was talking earlier
today up in Seattle about the European
Union so it's an absolute thrill to
better turn my attention to something
optimistic namely namely that's off the
record by the way namely the future of
Africa Africa for me is a an endless
source of fascination inspiration and
challenge I'm fascinated by the
possibilities inspired by the spirit and
challenged by the immensity of the
problems that ache for solutions ten
years ago when I addressed the world
sustainable development summit in
Johannesburg I was more daunted by this
challenge I focused on my commitment to
bringing aid to Africa leading to the
doubling of the aid agreed at the 2005
g8 Gleneagles summit and the
cancellation of debt ten years on though
my message is a lot more optimistic as
Garth was saying to you the pace of
change in Africa today is dizzying its
populations going to double by the mid
21st century seventy percent of Africans
are under the age of 30 in the last
decade six of the world's
fastest-growing economies were African
and foreign direct investment has grown
six-fold over that time consumer
spending over the next decade is set
almost to double and the middle class
also to double run about from sixty to a
hundred million people the number of
democracies also in sub-saharan Africa
has risen over the past 20 or 25 years
from around 3 to 23 deaths from malaria
hiv/aids and measles have reduced
dramatically literally hundreds of
thousands of lives being saved much of
this is a result of the aid which is so
crucial to maintain the challenge of
course is huge only one in four Africans
have a axe
- electricity in countries like Malawi
the figure is more like one in ten it is
the continent rich in agricultural
resources but is a net food importer and
still almost 1 million human beings die
every year from preventable diseases
mainly women and young children but
today the optimism we describe it's not
based on hope but experience today my
focus is not only on what we can give
but how we can partner today for me
governance the capacity of African
nations to make effective changes in the
lives of their people alongside that aid
commitment is the new approach to Africa
this is in my judgment what US and
European policy should have at its
centre and this approach is what I would
call a kind of muscular soft power
diplomacy it's using our technical
expertise our intellectual capital our
experience of what works in government
and using it in partnership with African
leaders so that African nations can
accelerate their development replace Aid
with investment and be masters of their
own destiny and the purpose of the
partnership is to empower that new
generation of politicians businesspeople
civic society organizers to create
sustainable political economic and
social growth sustainable because we're
doing it in partnership with them not
them waiting for us to do it for them or
even to them one thing I noticed from
all the different parts of the world I
see today from the Middle East to the
Far East from South America to
sub-saharan Africa is the real
distinguishing feature of successful
emerging nations today is the quality of
their governance now for years frankly
governance was the the poor relation of
foreign policy a few transparency
initiatives here training days for civil
servants there
it was basically the kind of eyes glaze
over part of the overseas aid in fact
because of the way today technology and
capital are so easily exportable and in
portable governance is actually the
cornerstone of development today and by
governments
I don't simply mean honest government of
course corruption is a massive issue and
transparent and accountable government
an essential precondition for a viable
future but it isn't enough good
government isn't just honest it also has
to be effective it has to know how to
get things done
vision papers most of them with grand
titles like 2020 vision 2030 vision
these are abundant in Africa the hard
part though is not the what it's the how
it's about deciding priorities creating
a plan of implementation and then
actually doing the damn thing
analyzing adjusting and adapting as you
go it's the same outside of Africa by
the way but it is in Africa where we for
our perspective here could make the
biggest difference and I want to give
you five illustrations of this and then
make a suggestion first the initial step
is often providing capacity around the
key decision-maker namely the president
and this is something we focus on at AGI
and you know it's very when you come
into government you know when I first
came into the governor in 1997 my party
had been in power for it out of power
for 18 years okay so we were a long time
out of power and I always remember my
very first day in Downing Street I went
into the Downing Street for the for the
first time or May the second and used to
be a tradition in in British politics
when the primary new prime minister
comes in the old one goes out the door
with the suitcases right and out the
back door then in the front door comes
the new Prime Minister I see comes in
and the tradition is that you've got the
door there in
a corridor and at the end of the
corridor you got the Cabinet Room and
alongside the corridor the civil
servants is supposed to line up and
applaud in the new prime minister right
so they say goodbye to the old one they
applaud the new one well the other lot
had been in power for 18 years so they
were kind of used to the other a lot of
people so when I went in there were
people sort of weeping and as I as I
went down the line so you know by the
end time I got to the end of line I felt
guilty about the whole thing but I was
remembered going in then to the Cabinet
Room at the end of this corridor and
that did the chief panjandrum of the
British system was the civil servant was
sitting in there and I just sort of sat
opposite him I've never been a
government before and he just said to me
in that very sort of clip British way
well done what now
and so I can sympathise what anyone who
comes into power in these positions and
sometimes what the presidents need in
those circumstances or Prime Minister's
it's very basic things like the
organisation of an efficient front
office scheduling proper planning
analysing how time is used which people
are seen how the business of government
is organized communications media
strategy and especially when countries
have emerged from prolonged periods of
insecurity and conflict the basic
apparatus of government is missing and
we have the means to help supply it this
is especially true in the process of
prioritization the biggest and toughest
thing for any government to do show me a
leader with a hundred priorities and
I'll show you someone who's going to get
nothing done choose three or four and
make them doable and something might
happen so give you a concrete example
AGI supported the government of Sierra
Leone in implementing their free
healthcare initiative through pregnant
women and children under five they've
been trying to do this for years they
had the money but not the capacity they
then did it three times as many
under-fives are now treated as a result
there has been an 80% reduction in
deaths amongst such tool
treated for malaria year-on-year from
now on 1 million children and 250,000
pregnant women will benefit from that
policy they just needed the capacity to
get it done so building that capacity
around the key decision-makers the first
thing the second thing is the clearest
necessities for most African nations
today are usually around infrastructure
energy electricity roads ports basic
infrastructure because of technology
notably the internet power is now the
vital prerequisite if you're getting the
lights on and you're getting online
combined with the explosion of mobile
telephony as Garth was saying it opens
up a country's potential in a way
nothing else can so in Nigeria which is
the most populous African nation 160
million people as the current government
rightly recognizes if they solved the
power problem they would have at least
half the answer to the problems of the
country but all over Africa there is a
desperate need for megawatts of
electricity then in our systems would be
considered almost trivial and in these
countries can transform the community so
when the presidents of Sierra Leone and
Liberia gave reliable electricity to
Freetown and Monrovia the effect was
twofold
people could work study and live better
but also they could see politics working
again we have expertise and experience
in this area and it matters far more
than the small scale projects that may
be very worthy in themselves but don't
actually don't actually get a nation on
its feet
third Africa urgently requires quality
foreign investment and private sector
growth one of the reasons why your seed
initiative here is so crucial I think
it's true the private sectors grown over
these past years but still today only 20
African companies have revenues of over
three billion dollars 60 percent of the
world's uncultivated land is in Africa
and many African countries
have enormous quantities of the
commodities the world needs but too
often they are exploited without
contributing to the country's overall
development but good quality foreign
investment doesn't happen by chance
neither does the encouragement of an
indigenous business community governance
and proper systems of attracting and
utilizing that investment are what
really counts but here again we find the
capacity so low so if countries want to
get in business investment from abroad
or build their business sector they've
got to have the capability to understand
what their opportunities are they've got
to market them judge the quality of
inward investors negotiate with them
nurture their own industry and create
synergies between the intellectual and
management capital that comes in from
the outside and the native business
already there in all of these areas help
is needed and in related fields for
example the rule of law predictable
judicial outcomes for business contracts
is of the essence it's what liberates
the possibility of inward investment
many countries don't have such systems
we can help provide the expertise to
make this possible fourth they have an
obvious requirement for education and
healthcare of course they do what we in
the West often do however from the
outside is we put money into discrete
educational health projects mainly local
usually very visible in bricks and water
or books and medicine now don't
misunderstand me
these are genuinely desirable they
change people's lives and of course they
play well to constituencies back home we
want to see their tax dollar put to good
use overseas however very often I'm
afraid they don't transform yet these
nations as they develop and their middle
class which in Africa means income of
over three thousand dollars per year as
they want better services they actually
need systemic change they need to
harness the best lessons
on education and healthcare reform from
around the world in fact they shouldn't
replicate or try to replicate our system
actually they should leapfrog many of
the constraints in limitations which the
legacy of our systems have created just
in the simple but actually revolutionary
use of technology alone they could
advance multiple times faster we have
that technology we also have the
experience of knowledge of what has
worked and what hasn't in our countries
we can supply the expertise and the
support to these countries to help make
that transformation and finally
countries don't prosper only through
strong and effective government or a
thriving private sector they also need
social capital they need civic
institutions of pride and purpose they
need community organizations basic law
and order free and responsible media and
the development of art and culture now
in our part of the world again we try to
do this not always well naturally but
where we fail we try to learn we can use
this knowledge and we can help build
these institutions of civic society so
this is why I think this issue to do
with capacity and governance is so
fundamentally important to the future of
Africa
it's my agenda for a new approach it
means a new partnership between
developing and developed nations not a
dependency these countries want to take
their own future in their own hands not
be dependent on us it means also a new
partnership however between our
traditional government agencies of
development in aid the new donors in
China India and Brazil now making their
own development policy the philanthropic
sector its enormous ly important sector
that's done so much in Africa in these
past years and of course the private
sector so the new approach is not just
north-south but within the north and
then within the south
now no discussion of Africa is adequate
today without the mention of China
China's investment in Africa has gone
from roughly six billion dollars in two
thousand to a hundred and ten billion
today China is actually going to put
more into infrastructure in Africa this
year than the whole of the World Bank
commitment now some see this as a threat
okay and I understand the concerns
around transparency but I also actually
see it as a spur to us many African
nations frankly welcome the speed of
Chinese investment and there get it done
attitude but they also want to balance
their new friendships then are naive
about this they want some balance there
they need us to be smarter faster and
more innovative to allow them to do so
building effective systems of delivery
so that more lives have changed for the
better more quickly that is what we can
do so my suggestion is this there is a
new crop of great new development
leaders in government like your own in
the US Russia but I think two of those
in Nordic countries Europe Canada
Australia even my own country the UK
there's also a new wave of
philanthropists people like Bill Gates
and of course many here today like Bob
and Dottie there's also a new sense of
corporate responsibility amongst the
major investments who use the
opportunities of Africa and understand
those opportunities but also know that
the best business done today is about
caring as well as capital and then
frankly since I know roughly half the
audience today or more students there's
you
people like Galan and and and Jonah and
the rest of you young people from all
over the world clever enough to get into
Stanford but compassionate enough to
come here today and listen to a speech
about a continent several thousand miles
away so we've got to work together I'm
going to put these different sources of
energy and commitment and drive and
innovation and creativity together and
in doing that we need to create new
streams of capacity expertise funding
and delivery that become effective
agents of change we have to join what is
in our minds to what is in our hearts
Africa is waiting but it's also moving
and we need to be part of that move
celebrating it but participating in it
and that's what we can do that is
actually the new approach to a new
Africa so let us go and do it thank you
which one you want thank you for those
remarks and thank you again for being
here it's wonderful to have you
listening to you the passion that you
bring to the African Governance
initiative is absolutely palpable could
you say something at a personal level
about what the source of that passion is
right boom first of all thank you Gotha
having hearing congratulations and being
in The Wall Street Journal this morning
so it's good to be with a media staff I
am actually with Africa my father taught
in Sierra Leone back in the 1960s and
here something is quite interesting
Sierra Leone back in the early 60s had
roughly the same GDP per head of South
Korea but today obviously not so you
know the history of many decades in
Africa was the history of wasted
opportunities mistakes that we made
mistakes that the countries made but in
this last decade I feel we've really
moved forward the countries have moved
forward and we've developed our own
thinking and and really I am passionate
about Africa today because I go to these
countries I mean Africa governance
initiative is in six countries now
probably may take on a seventh and you
know there's just fantastic people there
who given the opportunities are going to
create great countries in the future so
it's partly I have to say very you know
much about the excitement I feel and the
possibility there and and we need you
know a lot of the people who come and
work in our projects by the way this is
a recruiting pitch you know some
obviously we have older people with the
experience in in in government or the
private sector but we also get people
often fresh out of university we want to
come and spend a year or a couple of
years in one of these places and help
change your country it's just pretty
exciting thing to do tremendously
exciting so in our immediate
neighbourhood at Stanford University and
in Silicon Valley
more broadly there's a lot of emphasis
on the formation of new ventures
and on entrepreneurship and you spoke in
your remarks about the importance of
governance for business generally I'm
wondering about the link between
governance and entrepreneurship and
innovation and and whether that's
something that that AG I thinks about
and focuses on yes is a big part of our
focus but here again there's just been a
paradigm change in the last decade you
see today in the world there are vast
amounts of Footloose capital right so
there's you've got sovereign funds
you've got Chinese investors and Indian
investors and American European
investors looking for new opportunities
and often partly because of the
situation our own economies they're
looking for returns that they can get
elsewhere that they couldn't get in a in
our own situation but what makes them
come into a country right they could
have predictable rules they've got to
know that they don't have to carry a
suitcase of money to get the contract
they've got to know that that actually
if they come in this the country itself
is trying to build its infrastructure
you know they've got to have places they
can go places they can locate in time
there'll also be a demand for skilled
workers and so on in other words if
emerging market countries this doesn't
just apply to Africa actually get the
private sector framework right there is
no reason why any country cannot get a
massive amount of investment in I mean
then I've seen it happen you know so one
of the things that my people did in
Rwanda is we helped President Kagame
there we had a plethora of different
bodies doing bits and pieces of private
sector investment so we put it all in
one body which is Rwanda development
board we got frankly new people in to
run it we've got a group of young people
who really you know we're not about
keeping business out but bringing
business in that didn't have a sort of
bureaucratic attitude but had very much
a pro-business attitude and you know
inward investment in Rwanda is
increasing radically now likewise we did
a big conference for Sierra Leone in
London yeah we've got 1,500 people to
that investment conference out of it
came hundreds of millions of dollars of
investment so the thing that's so
important for countries to understand
is that actually it's it's really not
hard to know what you should do yeah
the difficulty is doing it so on exactly
that theme the the difference between
the what and the how that's something
that my colleagues in the business
school sometimes call the knowing doing
gap and you've addressed the the knowing
doing gap by embedding expertise in the
government's that face they face the
problem with the gap as a way of
addressing the gap so you know I imagine
that if I were to gather up 60 or 65 of
my MBA students and put them in a
classroom and say okay here's your role
you're one of these embedded helpers and
in one of these countries let's talk
about what some of the challenges might
be we would fill two white boards and in
no time it seems like a an extremely
daunting task to come in from the
outside and and and helping facilitate
so how do you think about that how do
you prepare people and what do you do to
ensure their success well first of all
the AGI differs from a traditional
consultancy not simply because it's a
not-for-profit and so on but it differs
in this way are people come and live in
the country they're not flying flyout
consultants secondly they work with an
appointed team from the other side in
other words we're about transferring
skill so when we started in Rwanda we
started with the president and building
capacity around the president we don't
work with indirectly in the president's
office anymore we're in different
departments now by the way the young
Rwandan --zz in his outfit working
around him I would have been happy to
have any of them in Downing Street so
you know basically people catch on fast
if they've got people working alongside
them and you you're getting the right
team work and the third thing is I
interact politically because the problem
were often with consultants from the
outside is you know politics is harder
than people think you know it really is
I mean you know by the way one of the
things I've learned since leaving office
is a dance I easier to give the advice
and take the decision you know that's
life I think but it's you know one of
the fascinating things I learned about
being a
a leader you see this is the journey of
politics of any of you ever undertake it
is you start at your you start at your
most popular and least capable and you
end at your least popular and most
capable that's the journey of leadership
and what I try to do that therefore is I
actually also interact politically with
the president so we try and give them
solutions they're also realistic you
know I read some some of the
international institutional reports to
some of these guys now I'm sort of
reading them thank you yeah that would
be great but there's no chance of any of
that happening
so practical solutions matter as well
and then you know a lot of this is just
about smart disciplined working and and
process now these countries can be very
difficult to work in they they can you
know you've got a lot of logistical
problems obviously and but just let me
sing on one thing which is energy and
power today because if you can get these
countries connected to the internet then
everything becomes very possible very
quickly by the way I mean that is you
know your thing about the mobile
telephones for 10 million to 750 million
I mean an important thing about that is
that's technology that's that's that
that means that liberates a whole sway
the people is there a lot of pushback
from observers on the outside saying why
you know why why are we reliant on help
from the outside I mean we we got we
we've had some from actually sometimes
less so now I think now that we've got
of track rocket record from the other
established donor community who kind of
say you know who these guys coming in
and yeah you do get pushback sometimes
from government but I mean we only work
by voluntary you know people need to
know what they want to have us in but
here's one of the things I'm always
saying to young leaders in in in Africa
you know whether you like every aspect
of Singapore or not what one of the true
you know
practically ders of the late 20th
century's Lee Kuan Yew
and and what he created in Singapore is
amazing but one of the things that marks
a real leader out is they don't care
where they get the expertise from they
just want to make the thing work and so
the interesting thing about Singapore
was when he first you know they were
chucked out of Malaysia they were trying
to build the country he just brought him
he brought some of the old British
Colonials back didn't care who they were
it didn't matter to him he had no there
was no sort of false pride about
accepting but today Singapore export
intellectual capital so what I'm always
saying obviously we can only work in a
country if people want us to but you
know I sometimes give my own example I
mean I made reforms in the UK healthcare
system you know brought in actually dare
I say with one or two Americans to help
with that process and it's you know yeah
you get a little bit of pushback but the
leaders who are good know that the only
thing that matters is delivery so you
said you're in six countries maybe going
on seven how do you think about the
country choice how do you how do you
decide where to go well it's a mix
they've they've got to want us and in a
sense we've got to want them so we've
got to work with leaders who are not
corrupt frankly we've got to work with
leaders who have a clear vision and work
with people who want our help but you
know it's it's amazing to see how very
quickly you can you know as thing I was
saying to you earlier that when we did
an analysis for one president of how
they used their time we found that less
than five percent of their times was on
their priorities so you have these
priorities but actually they weren't
spending any time on it one great advice
piece of advice that was given to me by
an a former president of yours President
Clinton actually was was this this is I
went to see him in in 1996 in the in the
White House when I was leader of the
Opposition and you know we had a good
meeting he leaving he said to me
I want to talk to you about something
really important and I thought you know
I was quite taken with this I thought I
was going to get some in straw Denari
piece of geopolitical insight there was
about to be he's he been president then
for a nice six years in his second term
I thought he's gonna tell me there's a
secret code he said I said so I was very
excited by so I said what is it and he
said I'm gonna talk to you about
scheduling and he he explained to me
which is absolutely right not that he
always does it or I always do it in the
way we think it should be done by the
way but he said to me you will find that
one of the hardest things when you get
in the government is finding the time to
think strategically is being able to
create the space so that you are focused
on what you really know counts because
otherwise he said the system will take
you over and you'll be a meetings from
8:00 in the morning till 10:00 at night
and you know you'll think you're
immensely busy but actually the tactics
and the strategy have all got mixed
together it was great advice which I
actually took and I found it invaluable
and one of the first things I say to any
prisoners where's your thinking time
where's your consideration of where am I
going what am I trying to do have I got
this thing really because what happens
in politics as well is that things come
at you the whole time
so you know there's a British Prime
Minister wasn't one Sassin he said it
was asked what's the most difficult
thing about government and he said
events did boy events so things happen
right and if you're not careful
something happens there's a some crisis
and you spend your time dealing with you
lose your strategic grip on what's going
to determine whether you're a successful
government or not
now these crises are real you got to
deal with them but actually when you
then judge your government in history
you know I think of the things that I
lost sleep on some of the you know
crises that suddenly came like sort of
foot-and-mouth disease away the fuel
strike or so nowadays no even remembers
any of those
but you've got to create the space to be
thinking strategically all the time yeah
and and when you think about the scope
of the assignment when when you're going
into one of these how do you think about
the the bounds and the limits on on what
it's a time bound is it is scope bound
or does it does it evolve it depends I
mean you know fortunately there's no
place yet we've been in that we've been
chucked out of service still there and
in the mall I I think it's you know it
really depends on the country but we
work out priorities with the the
president said and it's only when it
when it's helpful you know when they
find it helpful but I I think for most
of these countries they're engaged in
sort of 10-year program of change
reality I thought maybe we'd switch
gears a little bit and broaden the
discussion from AGI to aid and and and
debt more generally you've been a
tremendous champion of both foreign
assistance and embed relief as key
contributors to to growth and
development what do you see is the the
prospect for continued involvement with
the austerity that that seems to be
shaping the agenda and in Europe and
another place well I I mean I hope I was
having this discussion
Bill Gates when I was because I was
dressing a conference he was at earlier
today I think and it's really important
that we don't misunderstand the fact
that a low I think that Aid is not
enough aid has made a difference if you
take you your PEPFAR program in the u.s.
that just continuing under this
administration I mean you're measuring
things in hundreds of thousands of lives
you look at what the Gates Foundation
the Clinton Global Initiative and others
have done I mean you're talking hundreds
of thousands of people you know there
are something like two hundred thousand
fewer malaria deaths a year now than ten
years ago I didn't even five years ago
actually two hundred thousand two
hundred thousand people you know it's a
lot of people now so he does
matter the trouble with ade though is
ultimately I think it works better for
that type of thing
and you know when we cancelled the debt
of many of these countries a lot of them
were able then to fund free primary
education for the first time and so on
so all of this was important but I feel
myself that as Africa is shifted it's
also time to add this new dimension so I
don't add it in place of Aid and I think
for our communities by the way it is
important that our people cuz you know
you will face the same pressures as we
face in the UK I mean David Cameron the
UK Prime Minister has made a commitment
to maintain our position on aid and
that's tough to do you know I mean it's
a big commitment and something I applaud
by the way and but it's important that
people who are taxpayers in countries
going through periods of austerity also
understand this money is is actually
does result in live saves and and it's
an investment - for our future in Africa
today if I was to look at the
fragilities they would be around in
sub-saharan Africa for example if you
look at Nigeria the problems that they
got with terrorism now and so on and the
potential for conflict between different
faith communities you know if you look
at North and South Sudan if we're
helping South Sudan as a new country get
on its feet you know we hope to go work
there
that's that's a that's an investment for
our future and you know it's an
investment that is worth making so I
think we've got a rehearse and make
these arguments again otherwise I think
there is a risk that in times of
austerity certainly in Europe you know
people say well why we paying money to
those people over there rather than
spending it here so picking up on this
point about the UK I think that the UK
has been unusually successful at at
maintaining public interest in in the
development agenda and what do you think
that the secret is to that why is that
happened more in the UK than any other
place we've got a great campaign going
and before the 2005 summit g8 summit I
mean I
she made Africa and climate change the
two issues of that summit and you know
the I mean frankly some of the other
leaders are a bit surprised at the time
I think with Africa being there but we
got a great Civic Society campaign going
where you know the canceled the debt
campaign and so on and bottom and Bob
Geldof and all these people and then you
had the faith communities its civic
society and people got inspired by it
but you got to keep it going and so
became part of our political consensus
in in the UK and I do genuinely believe
this these countries are you know if a
country like Nigeria goes right it's
gonna be a great thing for the world if
it goes wrong it's going to be a problem
so I would love to monopolize your time
but I do think we we need to enter the
Twittersphere and see some what
questions and that's what you are and
that's what I'm doing right here so I'm
actually really impressed with this yeah
I must say we have a question from
Devesh Senapati who asks is
american-style democracy the right
governance model for the new Africa and
well these are bigger question but I
actually don't believe there is a an
American democracy or an African but I
think this is democracy you know I think
democracy is not just a way of voting by
the way of thinking and I think it's
basically pluralistic and open-minded so
I think in the end yes it is democracy
is the is the form of government that
most people will choose when they get
the chance to choose it I think there is
a stage of development in certain
countries particularly when they're
coming from a post-conflict situation
when you know as if we're you're not
going to go straight into if you like
full democracy I think you can see in
the Middle East there are issues as
countries try and evolve their systems
but in the end I think the most
effective you know you've got to trust
the people ultimately so but I think for
democracy to work it does need strong
institutions of governance and the rule
of law we have a question from Adam Kay
Adam is keeping a little bit of
anonymity
is Adam here
Adams here there's Adam hi so Adams
question is corruption often foils state
capacity how does a ji deal with
bureaucracies and leadership that is
fundamentally corrupt well we we get
quite honestly won't deal in a country
where the leadership is corrupt and it
is a problem it's a huge problem and not
just in Africa but I think there are
ways of dealing with it I actually have
come to this conclusion with corruption
that the best way of dealing with it is
to introduce systems that are themselves
transparent and and therefore have their
own protection against corruption so
there are two ways you deal with
corruption I think it's an interesting
argument in India as well by the way at
the moment do you as it were point a
point and anti-corruption czar and so on
and you know focus on individuals and so
on or do you in fact create systems for
example of public procurement or where
there is extractive industries systems
of attracting in in Wyndam of inward
investment
I actually think those give you better
protection so we work on that and we try
to minimize the corruption particularly
in the development of resources so it is
a problem it's an inhibition and and
look the problem with corruption is not
just that it's wrong it's that it's also
inefficient so we try and take discreet
areas of government if you like and at
least make sure working with the
president and their team that that bit
is is you know is immune from it all
protected against it and then I think
it's also very important at certain
points that the government moves against
people who are obviously are corrupt and
takes action against them but the best
way of dealing corruption I think is
systemic that's that's my view we have a
question from shadi bushra and shadi
asks how you think about prioritizing
governance versus accountability for
greater democratic freedom yeah this is
this is difficult and sometimes where we
do get criticism is people say you know
I I focus sort of so much on the
efficacy
and accountability is also important and
my attitude to this is it is but there's
lots of people who have focused on
accountability on transparency on some
of the very important issues to do with
human rights and so on what I actually
believe though about government in a lot
of these countries is that unless they
can get the lights on and the roads bill
and the food distributed and the
medicines distributed then nothing
happens and so you know I don't exclude
those things at all and and and by the
way we raise those issues but the focus
of AGI is efficacy I mean my theory of
government today is that government
really is about efficacy it's not so
much about ideology anymore now that is
quite disruptive for normal political
parties they love to think about
ideology very much but I actually think
today what most people want is to see
government getting things done moving
things and that's true by the way in our
country it's never mind African
countries but that's what I focus on
great so I think it would be remiss to
to let the the day go by without at
least commenting on Facebook given given
what tomorrow holds and so you spoke a
little bit earth
right look I know I'm a politician but I
because I'm out of practice a bit I
tried to talk only about subjects I know
something about better well no it's not
a characteristic of my profession but
it's not asking for a full cast on the
IPO opening pop but the question is this
which is you you mentioned earlier that
technology holds a lot of the keys for
for some of these countries and I'm
wondering specifically about the role of
social media in in both especially in
governance but but more generally and I
mean this is you know I find this whole
part of the world a fascinating sort of
intellectual ecosystem and the social
media that you've developed here I mean
look I don't understand a lot of it but
I do understand its importance it is a
revolutionary phenomenon and we're not
talking about the Middle East today but
this is a place I spend a lot of my time
in but it is it's its it generates the
most extraordinary waves of feeling and
emotion and opinion that it's impossible
for governments to control and it does
have its problematic aspects by the way
but it is extraordinary liberating for
people and it's a transformative fact so
I think social media is enormous ly
important I think politicians don't
quite yet know how to to get inside the
ability to communicate through it but it
does offer enormous opportunities and
technology one of the things that I
think is so fascinating to me about
emerging countries now is I think
technology offers them huge
opportunities for reform and change of
their basic systems and things like
education in healthcare where my
constant plea to them you know sometimes
I'll get a leader who says to me when
are we going to have an education system
like yours and I say don't ask because
basically we're now looking at our
education systems right run the Western
world and thinking how do we change
these pretty fundamentally in fact so I
would say
think about how you would use technology
today if you have the power and that's
why I say electricity and power is so
important in these countries think how
you use that today how would you teach
differently so how would you use
Facebook and even Twitter and other
forms of social media to to make these
changes so I think this is absolutely
essential and one of the things that I
think would be really interesting for
your work here in Stanford because
obviously if your your connection with
the development of social videos work
out how governments might use this how
might you change some systems of
government to do this you know how might
you improve I don't mean improve
communication between government and
people but how might you create better
systems of delivery in basic services I
think there are fascinating things that
could be done here I mean I would say to
people you know if we were looking at
creating healthcare systems in our
countries today certainly in my country
you know we would think very
fundamentally the first the starting
point would probably be technology right
now we don't look a little Isis because
we get a legacy of how these systems are
growing up over time but this is what I
think is is fascinating and interesting
so I couldn't really give you any advice
on the IPO but it isn't it is an
advantage from in many of these
economies that they're not burdened
actually with the legacy systems they
have they have Greenfield you look at
leap frogging via mobile phone and so on
yeah absolutely and look at I mean my
wife and she has got a great set of
projects on women's empowerment using
mobile telephones for women starting
their own businesses whose fantastic
program but I mean the possibilities are
huge and you know I think again one of
the things that we can do this is what I
would like to see our countries moving
to that more kind of dynamic engagement
that's why I call it a muscular soft
power diplomacy by which I mean it's not
just kind of nice projects that make
good pictures but it's actually things
that where we use something we have
that maybe other development partners
don't have and try and use that going
going back to to Twitter we have a
question from ana Clara cream who asks
what are the education challenges in
Africa and how does AGI approach that um
well the education challenges are
enormous I mean there are still large
numbers of kids that don't go to school
or the schooling is a very poor quality
and I don't want to repeat what I've
just said about technology and but in
the end what will matter enormous ly to
these African countries is to develop
proper systems of Education but I think
they should develop their own systems in
their own way should learn lessons from
us but not replicate I think we have
time just for one more and I'll take it
from Twitter a hun Dan Kabir asks how do
you see the role of Western foreign
policy evolving in a post Arab Spring
world of self-reliance versus
autocracies well I mean we've got a big
challenge here I mean we're talking
about Africa although some of the same
issues are there but I mean we've got
two big challenges which is why I
understand the desire of of Western
governments in a way to disengage at the
moment from the world's problems because
our internal issues are so great but I
think we've got to stay engaged and in
these developing democracies in Africa
and in the Arab world we've got to
understand there's two big challenges
the first is on the economy because
these populations are young and they
need jobs and they need proper Economic
Policy I had a conversation with some
young Egyptians a few weeks back which
was fascinating but also a little
alarming and they kind of said to me you
know it's fantastic we got our democracy
and I said them so what's your economic
policy and they said to me what we got
our democracy there I said no I know but
I mean the democracy is a means of
deciding your government it doesn't
what's your tax policy what's your
spending policy do you think more
industry should be in the private sector
or do you think the state
to control it all said well we got our
democracy so you know I think we need to
engage and help these countries remember
a country like Egypt in the 1950s at a
population of 30 million today it's 90
million
the average age all over the Arab world
which is the population of which is set
to double in the next 25 years so you've
got massive issues here we've got to
deal with the second thing is about
democracy I think the most important
thing is for us to be able to help
educate the world whether in Africa or
elsewhere you know because it's taken us
centuries you know we forget this taking
our centuries to develop our democracy
you know in the UK it was only in the
1920s we had proper universal suffrage
the democracy is a way of thinking and
not just a way of voting right so
democracy isn't just about the freedom
to vote it's about freedom of expression
it's actually about free markets free
enterprise it's about you know albeit
with regulation and state intervention
and so on it's about freedom of religion
very very important it's actually
pluralistic democracy is not about the
majority ruling simply it's also about
the tolerance of minorities it's about
the concept of what I would call
open-mindedness I mean I think the great
political divide in the world today is
yes this is sort of legacy of left and
right which is very important in our
systems in your country in my country
but I think in many ways this is an
essentially 20th century distinction the
big dividing line I see in politics in
the world today is been in what I will
call the open and the closed mind you
know the open-minded see globalization
as an opportunity they see its challenge
as spreading the benefits of
globalization you know they have an open
mind on trade migration you know people
of different faiths and culture I
believe in the open-minded approach the
closed-minded sees differences of threat
takes it out on immigrants or people of
different faiths or people different
culture this challenge
- between the open-minded and the
close-minded I think is absolutely the
heart of it so when we're engaging with
the Arab Spring or that the democracies
that are developing in the world today
which we should engage in single this is
actually what democracy means and we
should be supporting the modernizing
reforming open-minded tendencies in all
these countries and we should be helping
them take the right economic decisions
with the support that we can give in
order their people of Economic
Opportunity along with political
empowerment so I think that's the big
challenge and I think a great thing
about a school like Stanford is that you
you know you're a great repository of
the open mind and we need that and we
need that that sense of empowerment to
be there and you know it's a fascinating
thing I I I grew up in north of England
in a place called County Durham which
mostly won't know about but it's
something up in the north of England and
I I remember when I growing up there
I actually remember the day when I was
12 years old I met my first non-white
person right everyone was the same
everyone look the same thought the same
was basically the same faith and culture
my actually this weekend to be 12 year
old son my youngest son and when he will
have his birthday party he will probably
have four different faiths represented
around you know the table of the party
now I actually like that world I think
this is a great way I think I think that
that one of the saddest things is when
you know differences of culture and race
and issues to do with immigration get
exploited politically because in fact
it's an enormous ly enriching thing that
we get people coming for example to
London from all over the world today
people mixing together and living
together and working together I think
this is a great new world okay but I
think we've got to go out there and be
prepared to proclaim it and stand up for
it and you know be prepared to
to believe in its values and and and and
help bring them to the parts of the
world that don't have it and I think we
should always remember when we're at an
institution like this how incredibly
blessed we are how lucky we are to be in
it
you know how the fact that the so many
people can come for so many different
parts of the world and be here and
participate in this extraordinary
development of the open mind
we are lucky well but there's so many
other parts of the world that don't have
that benefit so as we're thinking about
how we the students think about how we
succeed in life and get on and do well I
think it's also important that we give a
bit of our time and a bit of our mind to
how we help those people that don't have
those blessings in their life that's a
wonderful note on which day thank you so
much for being
you
change
anja lives change organizations diabetes
organizations change the world